now the uh your former colleague the
former financial secretary to the
treasury jesse norman has written a
letter today calling on the prime
minister to resign do you agree with him
no
no no
um you worked with him for a couple of
years you must have some respect for him
i i i've of course i've worked with uh
with jesse for a while since i had this
job and he did a very good job and i'm
grateful for the job he did it did for
me
um in his letter jesse norman says uh to
the prime minister that uh to describe
yourself as vindicated by the sue grey
report is grotesque
do you agree with his judgment on that
does it say i'm not entirely sure what
this has to do with the statement but i
disagree with him as i i said and i
support the prime minister and but thank
jesse for the job he did when he was a
minister in in the treasury i think
political stability has quite a lot to
do with how we perform economically
chancellor um in his letter he also says
breach of the northern ireland protocol
which is what's being constantly
threatened by this government would be
economically very damaging politically
foolhardy and almost certainly illegal
do you agree with him about that
so that that's that's not the intention
the intention is to have a as a dialogue
with our partners which we're continuing
to do to make sure that we can try and
reach a sensible settlement to some of
the challenges that we're seeing new
york northern ireland's place in the
united kingdom economically where there
are very clear challenges and the
protocol is you know proving to be a
barrier to a resumption of a functioning
executive in northern ireland it's right
that we try and take steps to address
that do you agree
uh with the uh prime minister's
anti-corruption champion
uh john penrose who resigned
today because he judges that the prime
minister has broken the ministerial code
and ought to resign
again i disagree yes
thank you very much